so thank you everyone for uh
showing up to this final lecture in the
boot camp series
once again i'm very pleased to introduce
ankur moitra from mit
he'll be completing his excellent series
on learning
in high dimensions so please take away
ankur
great so thanks everyone for making it
all the way through until the end
so today i'm gonna ask a somewhat
conceptually different kind of question
that i asked in
the first three lectures so in the first
three lectures i gave you a variety of
different techniques for designing
proofable algorithms for high
dimensional learning problems
and these were mostly problems that were
motivated by data science things like
you know learning mixture models
sometimes they
the motivations came from other
neighboring domains like in photogenic
reconstruction
and then we talked about you know how to
deal with robustness both in
unsupervised learning contexts and in
supervised learning contexts like when
you want to learn some sort of decision
boundary
but today i'm going to ask a
qualitatively different sort of question
which is whether
these types of tools specifically things
that have been useful like tensor
methods for designing provable
algorithms
might also be useful in neighboring
disciplines like physics
so i think the stock really comes from
the fact that i sit in a math department
so i see
all kinds of applied mathematicians
working on inverse problems for
you know in in engineering problems and
a lot of these engineering problems they
really
seem to me to resemble a lot of the
types of problems that we do study at
least conceptually within theoretical
machine learning
so i'm going to ask ask their approved
algorithms have something
interesting to say in fact i only really
know one example so let me tell you
something about a particular
inverse problem that shows up in physics
specifically in
optics so of course
i expect most of you probably aren't
familiar with a lot of optics but let me
explain the setup so in in optics you're
thinking about observing some object
through an optical system usually a lens
and you can think about this maybe in
the context of astronomy that this
object is so far away that you can
basically treat it as a point source now
it's luminous so you observe
light from this point source and you
need some sort of model of the lens and
usually you model it as something with a
circular aperture and that's a very good
approximation in most settings
and you also need one more key property
is that the light that you're observing
is incoherent
and when you do this when you observe a
point source that's far away through a
circular aperture you get a diffraction
pattern on your observation plane
and the observation pattern that you get
from a single point source is called
an airy disk so let's talk about what an
airy disk is well first let me define it
as a function
so an erie disk involves bessel
functions so you take a bessel function
j1 of the first kind it's not really
important for the stock what exactly it
is
and there's also a parameter sigma that
you should think of as controlling the
blur
so in fact the larger sigma is the more
that this point source
is blurred out so this is what the airy
disk is at some
function that depends on these bessel
functions and this blur parameter sigma
now if you think back to the physical
setup in optics where you have a lens
well actually the properties of your
optical system are the things that
determine the amount of blur that you
observe
so things like the numerical aperture
for your lens are things that go into
how you should think about sigma is
being set now one thing to keep in mind
is that these airy discs are pretty
interesting objects if you look very
close to their center
they look a little bit like a gaussian
they have a peak at the center and then
they decay
but then they're actually a little bit
different because they have oscillation
and you can see these different rings
occurring and this is called the airy
disk
and there's a nice interpretation of
what this airy disk means
well you can do this through feynman
path integrals but what it is
is this area disk function tells you the
infinitesimal probability of detecting a
photon
at some position in the observation
plane so it's literally a sampling model
where you're thinking about sampling
photons
from this underlying diffraction pattern
that's itself a density function
and this diffraction pattern is actually
first computed way back when back in
1835 by sir
george biddle erie and that's why
they're called the arie discs
so now what is the diffraction limit
well it's a rough idea in the first
place which is that
you know for more than a century and a
half really since aries work
it was widely believed that this physics
imposes some kind of fundamental limit
onto resolution
and so the way to think about it is what
if you're observing not one point source
but two point sources well that's going
to create a superposition of airy disks
a mixture
of airy disks and that's why it's
important that these
point sources are incoherent is that
they don't actually
interfere with each other so instead you
just get the superposition
of these two density functions and the
idea is that
as you take these point sources and you
move them closer and closer together
eventually it seemingly becomes very
hard to tell
whether it's a single airy disk or it's
two airy disks
so this problem literally arises in
astronomy where you're looking out of
the night sky
and you observe a star or what you think
is a single star
but you have the problem that it's very
hard to tell whether it's one star
or it's actually a double star because
two things are very close by
to each other
so the main question that i'll be
interested in is is there a way to
actually make this
rigorous so instead of just
heuristically believing that when they
get closer and closer together it seems
hard to disentangle these two airy disks
what we want to understand is whether
there really are hard and fast
statistical and algorithmic limitations
that arise when we want to estimate a
mixture of airy disks
and this is what i mean when i say we
want to study statistical and
algorithmic foundations for
the diffraction limit so actually
another
funny quirk in history is that um you
know not only is this diffraction limit
a somewhat fuzzy concept
but when people have sat down and tried
to figure out what exactly
is the fundal limit what audit be
they've come up with a variety of
different answers
you know since since aries original work
so in particular people have studied the
question you know what should be the
minimum separation that you can hope to
resolve in this kind of setup
and how does that minimum separation
depend on the parameters of your optical
system
so in some context this means you know
if i want to build a larger lens
well how much more resolution power does
that actually buy me in terms of being
able to resolve closely spaced stars in
the night sky so about 30 years
after after aries original work
raleigh suggested a simple criteria that
i'll talk more about later
that he said that it's only possible to
resolve things which are roughly 1.22
times pi times sigma separated from each
other
so that needs to be the minimum
separation between the centers the airy
disks
because otherwise he believed that it's
just impossible to actually try and
resolve beneath that
that threshold and actually there's been
a lot of work
over the years suggesting many different
criteria
which lead to many different constants
and
the question that i want to ask is which
if any of these criteria is the right
one and is there a way to make this
problem mathematically rigorous and
understand
what the diffraction limit ought to mean
so it's fun to dig into some of the
history actually um
my student ceton you know managed to
find all of these amazing gems in the
you know the physics literature and dig
into why they thought the diffraction
limits were
where they were so back in 1879
lord raleigh proposed that raleigh
criteria
and he proposed that really just as a
heuristic he said the rule is
convenient on account of its simplicity
and is sufficiently accurate in view of
the necessary uncertainty
as to what exactly is meant by
resolution so he meant it
just as some sort of rule of thumb about
where you should draw the line between
what you can actually resolve
and beneath which you should just think
about as being noise that you can't hope
to figure out what's going on
but over time people thought that the
diffraction limit ought to actually mean
something much sharper and they came up
with different constants
there were all kinds of refinements to
raleigh's criteria
and they were all based on varying
degrees of rigor in fact
one of my favorite quotes here is uh due
to carol sparrow so this was back in
1918
so not only did he suggest a different
criteria than raleigh's criteria but
he was rather bold about it so he said
it's
obvious that the undulation conditions
should set an upper limit to the
resolving power
actually that's a recurring theme you'll
see that many of these quotes
people say things like it's obvious
without actually supplying any
mathematical argument
in fact he goes on to say to you know to
give a proof in his own way
that my own observations on this point
have been checked by a number of
colleagues
friends and colleagues so you know
that's his argument is that
if you can't see that this is the true
diffraction limit
then you know everyone else can see it
my colleagues and my friends
and in fact over the years some people
have even pushed back on the idea of
there
actually being a diffraction limit at
all in fact there's this beautiful quote
to the feynman
in his famous introduction to physics
lecture series back in 1964
where he said in when discussing
raleigh's criteria
well it seems a little pedantic to put
such precision
into the resolving power formula
actually if sufficiently careful
measurements of the exact intensity
distribution over
the diffracted image can be made the
fact that two point sources make the
spot can be proved
regardless of separation so he's pushing
back on this idea that you know he's
really saying that you can actually go
beneath the diffraction limit if you
really want to
specifically in the case where you just
have two point sources and that there
aren't any fundamental limits
to learning mixtures of two airy disks
regardless of their separation
so it's kind of a subtle thing because
over the years
different communities that rely on
optics
they have their own beliefs about which
of the criteria are the right ones
you know there are different criteria
that are that are believed when you're
talking about resolving inside the cell
versus resolving stars
and nevertheless there is actually a lot
of empirical evidence that
you know for some types of systems that
we're trying to observe via optical
systems there is a limit to what we can
resolve
so can we put this on a rigorous
foundation
so let me tell you about some recent
results and
for those who are familiar with things
like learning mixture models they're
going to be a lot of parallels between
the types of mixture models that we
study in theoretical computer science
and the types of mixture models that are
arising in these optics problems and
these inverse problems in physics
so the first thing this is the less
surprising the results is that
you know we actually do give provable
algorithms for learning
mixtures of airy disks that have
non-asymptotic
guarantees and that work regardless of
the separation
so if you have two airy discs if you
have any constant number of airy discs
indeed there isn't actually any real
diffraction limit
you just need to take more and more
samples and run in a larger amount of
time
but you really can go beneath the
diffraction limit
so what we showed was that given samples
from a delta separated
mixture of k-airy disks so that means
that the centers are
delta apart from each other in l2
distance and these are all things that
are happening in two dimensions because
you're thinking about the centers
as being locations in the observation
plane
and there's a notion of a relative
intensity lambda which is really just
the mixing weight so what fraction of
the photons come from which of the
different sources
so as long as you have a lower bound on
the relative intensity of all of the
different sources
then there is a polynomial time
algorithm for any constant k
that takes a polynomial number of
samples and learns
the centers of the area disks to any
desired accuracy
epsilon and with small failure
probability delta
so just to take a step back because you
know a lot of these theorems that i'm
going to tell you about today are not
technically hard especially given all
that we know
especially in theoretical computer
science about how to learn mixture
models how to learn mixtures of
gaussians and things like that
well i think it's still good to come
back and think about
you know how these results relate to
some of the debates that were had within
physics over the years and actually many
of those
arguments about different constants
being the right one for the diffraction
limit
they're all based on some thought
experiments about what happens
when you have two different arie discs
that are very close to each other
they all differ in you know how exactly
close those airy discs need to be
for you not to be able to tell that it's
two some of them are undulation criteria
like
sparrows criteria some of them are
different
like when they become unimodal in the
middle when they're so close that the
middle hump you can't see a double hump
anymore
but because they're all based on the
idea of pushing
two airy discs closer and closer to each
other they're not actually statistically
well founded because it doesn't actually
matter how close they are
you can still resolve them if you really
use the fact that it is honestly an airy
disk
that shows up in these types of
diffraction patterns
so there really is no fundamental limit
to diffraction there is no resolution
limit
and this is making good on this
assertion that feynman had in his
lecture series
now i think the second part of the
results are you know more unexpected
from a physics standpoint
because almost all of these arguments
about the existence or in existence of a
diffraction limit we're all based on
thinking about mixtures of two airy
disks
but actually something funny happens
when you take the number of dairy disks
to be large
is that it turns out that there actually
is a phase transition so you actually
can make sense
of what it means for there to be a
diffraction limit
because you see the difference between
needing to run in poly and k
sample complexity or instead needing
exponential in k sample complexity
so at the same time when the number of
centers is large there actually is an
honest phase transition in what you can
resolve
statistically and algorithmically and
what you cannot hope to resolve
so here we're not exactly going to be
able to pin down the precise
constant but we're going to pin it down
to within a range
so let me define two constants gamma
plus will be some constant that depends
on some properties of bessel functions
that's this parameter j01
i won't get into what that is but it
works out to be about 1.53
and there's an explicit construction for
a lower bound where you just can't hope
to resolve these different
uh separated point sources where the
separation is about
1.15 and so we prove
on the algorithmic side is that you know
when you talk about this gamma plus
separation
if the mixture of k aridis has the
property that its centers
are gamma plus times pi times sigma
separated
then there really is a polynomial time
algorithm that's now polynomial in
all of the parameters of the problem
polynomial in the number of centers
polynomial in one over the minimum
separation delta
polynomial and one over lambda where
lambda is the lower bound of the
relative intensity
and one over epsilon where epsilon is
the failure probability sorry there
should also be a poly log and one over
delta
but there's an honest poly in k time
algorithm with that number of samples
too
and conversely it turns out that beneath
some other constant times pi sigma
beneath the separation 1.15 times pi
sigma
then there really are separated mixtures
of k-airy disks
that you need exponential and k many
samples to learn
so this means that if you're in some
settings where you can't hope that there
are few point sources
well you really can say that for any
reasonable experimental setup
there's no hope for you being able to
resolve that number of point sources
because if you think back to the
original experiment where you have this
optical system and you're observing
these point sources
well any reasonable physical setup has
some
limitations because each one of the
photons that you observe is like a
sample from the diffraction pattern
and ultimately in your experiment you
know you start counting photons at some
time zero and you stop at some time t
you always have a finite exposure time
so you're only
ever observing a finite number of
photons
and the truth is that beneath some
diffraction limit the number of photons
you need explodes so
fast that you really can say it's not
reasonable
to pick out where these point sources
are up to better than this resolution
so i think this is a neat way that
provable algorithms can contribute to
inverse problems in the sciences is that
on the one hand we can actually prove
fundamental limits
to the fact that hey you can't actually
resolve at that
level of granularity that you think you
can in fact there are other types of
you know limitations in terms of the
experiment that naturally
are very related to things like the
sample complexity
because the truth is that even when you
observe the location of a photon
in the observation plane well ultimately
you're going to measure its location
through some apparatus and you can't
hope to record its precision
if it's location of arbitrary precision
at best you can do it up to some finite
accuracy and
those types of limitations in your
experimental setup are actually very
related
to having you know sample complexity
limitations on how many photons you can
observe
ah great i think i just answered the
question that was
in the q a which is are you taking into
account the granularity of the screen
where the photons hit
so i can talk about this a little bit
more later because i don't want to get
too sidetracked but
these two are related because you know
if you only record the location of a
photon up to some finite precision
then we'll see that the natural way that
you try and get an approximation the
true diffraction pattern is you try and
smooth
the empirical distribution of what
photon you observed approximately where
by some kind of smooth function so
that's the same way that you cope with
things like only having a finite number
of samples
both of these two things are kind of
related because the underlying arie disk
is itself a smooth function
so when you don't record the location
precisely
you can think about it also as being
like an error
almost in you know along the y-axis
instead of the x-axis
so thanks great um you know this will be
a little bit more of a philosophical
talk than usual so let me pontificate
even more
which is that you know people have
continued to be
interested in questions about the
diffraction limit for a very long time i
mean
interest has continued all through the
years you can still find modern surveys
written within the last few years about
these kinds of topics
and what's really funny is that in
different communities they have
different beliefs
if you're studying optics questions in
astronomy you don't believe there's a
diffraction limit at all in fact you
have great heuristics
that can and do work beneath the
diffraction limit
because when you're observing these uh
double star single star
all you do is you try out two different
airy discs and you try out whether you
find a good
fit to the scattering function that
you're observing by putting those two
area discs very close
to each other if it's a good enough fit
you conclude
that it's two are discs and not one and
that's a double star
but the trouble is that these are all
heuristics within astronomy you don't
actually know
that you're provably you know figuring
out whether it's one star or two stars
you have no way to control things like
what's your false discovery rate
and at the very other end of the
spectrum you have things like microscopy
where your goal is to look inside a cell
and what's going on in a molecular level
and here the limits in an optical sensor
a little bit different because you have
some instrument you're using to peer
inside the cell
but the trouble is that you know if you
really wanted to observe the cell at a
finer and finer granularity
that means you need to use higher
frequency light and higher frequency
light has more energy
so after a certain point you would
actually destroy the cell the thing that
you're trying to measure
so people have long believed that
they're fundamental limits within
microscopy
and those are settings within the cell
where you have tons of closely spaced
sources
and there people really do believe that
there is some kind of fundamental limit
but what they believe is the limit is
somehow a bit different than what other
communities do they're big believers in
the houston criteria instead of the
other things
so this is kind of neat because i think
some of these provable guarantees help
explain
why there are such differences between
these two different communities that
simultaneously there can both be no
diffraction limit
and yet really an honest-to-god
diffraction limit
it's just that it emerges as a phase
transition when you talk about the
number of sources
and one thing i want to mention which is
actually the reason that i got
interested in this in the first place
that's maybe a story for another time
but somewhat recently back in 2014
there was a nobel prize in chemistry for
super resolution cameras and the super
resolution
cameras you know are about breaking the
classical diffraction limit even though
we didn't really know what the
diffraction limit meant in the first
place
because what super resolution cameras do
is they take the cell that you want to
observe
and it has tons of these closely spaced
point sources that you want to figure
out where they are and what they're
doing
and what you do is you chemically tag
them with different kinds of chemicals
so that they only respond to certain
wavelengths of light
and in this way what you're doing is
you're effectively down sampling the
objects that you want to observe
because now when you measure with some
particular frequency of light you only
get a subset of the objects and they're
better spaced
so these types of things have been you
know nothing short of a miracle in
biochemistry
because they do some pretty spectacular
things like you can actually
see through super resolution cameras and
piece together
what it looks like when the hiv virus
enters a cell
and that's not something that you can do
with traditional microscopy and
traditional optics techniques
so in fact some of these approval
algorithms i think they make sense of
you know what is the rigorous notion
of what diffraction limit these super
resolution cameras purport to be
breaking
and there's a lot more to do here to
think about other physical setups and
what types of
inverse problems they lead to so can
provable algorithms in machine learning
contribute to this discussion
in optics and more broadly in physics
and the sciences
i hope that the answer is yes and let me
dig into at least one positive example
okay so there's something else cool that
you can do which is
you know you can ask to visualize what
these diffraction limits look like see i
made this claim
that the diffraction limit you know it's
not something that happens when you have
two airy discs it's not something that
happens when you have three are disks
but it's something that emerges when you
take the number of arie discs to be
large
so let's try and visualize that now i'm
going to simplify the setup a little bit
because
in for simplicity i'm going to assume
that all of the point sources are along
the same
1d line in this 2d space because in that
setting when all of the point sources
are on
just a single line it turns out that we
don't have gaps between our upper and
lower bounds
we can exactly nail the constant the
correct constant is one
and it's called the abbe diffraction
limit and in this setting what we can do
is we can try out two different
hypotheses what if i vary the number of
centers k
and i create one hard mixture of arie
dis and another hard mixture of arie dis
that try to look like each other and i
can ask how many samples would i need in
order to solve this hypothesis testing
problem
of which of the two mixtures it was
and what you can see is that i'm going
to plot the natural log
of the total variation distance between
these two different hypotheses
so really it's the exponential of this
y-axis
represents the number of samples you
need the number of photons you need the
number of precision you'd need in your
measurements of the locations of the
photons
in order to provably distinguish between
these two hypotheses
and right here along the x-axis i'm
going to normalize things
so that the abbe diffraction limit
happens right at zero because i'm taking
the natural log of the separation
divided by pi
and i've set sigma to be equal to one
and you can see what happens with the
diffraction limit because it's actually
something
visual because as soon as you vary the
number of centers you know if you take
two centers
there is no diffraction limit when you
go way beneath the abbe diffraction
limit how much does it
change you know how many samples you
need in order to resolve up to the
precision given by the abbey limit
up to some way sharper precision that's
way beneath the diffraction limit
it doesn't change by a whole heck of a
lot and that's why in astronomy visually
you don't need you don't have to believe
in the diffraction limit there are
heuristics that
you can actually provably analyze but in
contrast when you have something like
you know 90 point sources which is
really not an uncommon thing when you
talk about the cell in fact you'd have
way more than that
you can see that there's an inflection
point that once you move beyond the abbe
diffraction limit
well i guess you can go a little bit
beneath it if you have tons and tons of
sample complexity
and if your apparatus is so fine-tuned
that you can really measure the
locations of these photons
to some very sharp precision but once
you start going beneath that
it's just not possible you know how can
you measure the location of a photon
up to precision in the location e to the
minus 35
we're not going to do that so you know
there really is a fundamental limit that
happens just through statistical
considerations about what you're doing
and really owing to a lot of the
insights that you know for those of you
who are very familiar with theoretical
computer science
learning mixtures of gaussians things
like that the story i'm going to tell
you
has you know a whole heck of a lot of
parallels to that
other story and that's what i mean when
i say that i think a lot of these
algorithmic insights might actually have
something interesting to say in these
neighboring domains
all right so i can tell you a little bit
about you know what goes into the
techniques because
you know i don't want to get too much
into the techniques but i want to at
least give you an idea about
why there ought to be a diffraction
limit and where it comes from
and really a lot of it is going to come
through thinking about the fourier
transform
and through thinking about some
algorithm that's called the matrix
pencil method so let me dig into some of
the ideas
nothing here is very hard this will
actually be very simple especially if
you know
some of the earlier works on learning
mixtures of gaussians
so what i claim is that the inverse
probably want to solve we can think
about it as a deconvolution problem
because you know what we have before we
have these airy discs is we have their
centers
so we just have these delta functions at
these different
centers of these area disks and then
what happens
is that we convolve by an airy disk and
that gives us these superpositions of
these different airy disks
now all of these airy disks have the
same blur because they come from the
same optical system
whatever lens you're using has the same
numerical aperture
and that's why you can express it this
way is the convolution of
you know a bunch of delta functions
representing the centers
along with this arie disk function
so it turns out that there's a very
natural strategy for solving a
deconvolution problem
is you can just use the fourier
transform and divide
so nothing fancy is really going to
happen here but it will be slightly
subtle in some ways
so let's talk about the diffracted image
so first we have these relative
intensities the lambda sub js remember
these are
like the mixing weights because they
represent what fraction of the photons
are coming from the jth
point source when you're looking up in
astronomy
different stars have different
luminosities the more luminous ones
represent a larger fraction of the
photons are observing the observation
plane that's where this comes from
and then you have these airy disks but
the difference is that it's not i of x
it's i of x minus mu j because you're
shifting it so that it's at the location
muj
and just to make sure we're on the same
page this mu j is a point in two
dimensions
because it's really it's location in the
observation plane
the place where you're collecting the
different photons
so i said that the fourier transform is
very important and it is
so let's take the fourier transform
that's called p hat of w
now it's a nice linear function the
fourier transformation so
we get still this linear combination of
these mixing weights lambda j
no surprise there we get the fourier
transform
of the airy disk that's going to play a
really key role
but now what does translation do when we
translate the center from 0 to the
location uj
that corresponds to multiplying by
trigonometric function
so instead it's e to the minus 2 pi i
remember mu j is a is a dimension two
vector because it's a location in the
observation plane
omega here is a length to vector 2
because we're working in two dimensions
in this fourier transform
we take the inner product and that
becomes the frequency in this
exponential
so this fourier transform is going to
play a key role
and you know i didn't really tell you
what the arie disc looks like
functionally i just said it has to do
with bessel functions
well this is analytically what the
fourier transform of an erie disk looks
like
this actually might look kind of like a
mess but the way to think about it is
that what it looks like
is you take the indicator function of a
ball in two dimensions
and you convolve that indicator function
with itself
this is actually what fraunhofer
diffraction tells you happens even if
you don't have a circular aperture
you take the cross section through your
lens and then you take that
and you convolve it with itself and
that's the thing that describes your
scattering function
anyways no matter that's just some
intuition about the physics
the important thing about what this
function i hat of w looks like is
actually very simple
all we're going to care about really is
where it's 0 and where it's not 0.
so if you look at this function i claim
it's non-zero
strictly inside the disk of radius one
over pi
sigma that's the key point centered at
zero
now why is it important where i hat of w
is zero versus non-zero
is because our idea for deconvolving by
an airy disk
is to try and get rid of this i hat of w
really i want to take some approximation
to p hat of w
and i want to divide through so that i
kill this i hat of w
term and i'm only left with the lambda
j's and these exponential terms
so that's the question that i'm after is
can we remove this i hat of w
term now if there are locations where i
hat of w
is zero then we can't hope to divide
because we're not allowed to divide by
zero
so really what i mean is i want to
remove this i hat of w
term but we'll only be able to query the
result
in the region where the i hat of w was
non-zero to begin with
so this is one of the key lemmas it's a
pretty simple thing actually
which is that what i claim is that if
we're given samples from this
from this scattering function rho of x
then what we can do is algorithmically
we can say we can simulate
noisy access to the following
exponential sum where i've removed the i
hat of w
term and this will be a really useful
exponential sum for us because
through querying it we're going to hope
to try and learn the parameters
of the mixture we're going to hope to
try and learn the lambda js
and the mu chase that's the overall goal
so you know how does this thing work and
actually let me emphasize one key thing
which is that
this exponential sum you know as i was
alluding to before
i can't hope to query it anywhere i want
for any possible omega
i can only hope to query it for omegas
within some bounded disk
i'm only allowed band limited access to
f of omega
so that's the sense in which many sort
of heuristics for you know thinking
about inverse problems in optic systems
whatever optical system you're thinking
about whether it's you have a giant lens
and you're looking at stars
or you're sending light into a cell to
try and measure what's going on in the
cell
the basic assumption or onsites is that
all of these things are somehow
banned limited access to these point
sources that you want to be measuring
and this lemma makes it precisely clear
that you know you
literally have band limited access
you're only allowed to query f of omega
within this bounded disk so now how do
we prove this lemma and how do you
actually solve this deconvolution
problem
so this thing is actually pretty easy
it's uh it's using the following simple
procedure
so first i draw a bunch of samples from
rovex i observe
tons and tons of photons and i look
record approximately where they are in
the observation plane
now that's not going to be a good
approximation of row of x because that's
a discrete distribution
right so you know how should i go about
using those samples to create a good
approximation the row of x you know
that's also continuous too
is i take a bunch of samples from rho of
x and then i take that empirical
distribution and i smooth it by
convolving
by a small variance gaussian if you're a
statistician
this is called a kernel density estimate
and this
intuitively works and you can prove it
anytime you have
any smooth density function you take
enough samples and you smooth what you
observe and that will be a good
approximation to the unknown
distribution
so that's great because it gives us some
approximation to rho of x
now how do we take that approximation of
rho of x and turn it into an
approximation to rho hat of d of omega
well we just take its fourier transform
that's it
so when i take its fourier transform
we're going to get a good approximation
to rho
hat of omega the fourier transform of
the true
scattering function and then all we do
is we pointwise divide
by this fourier transform of the arie
disk within the part
where it's non-zero that's it and this
solves this as the thing that proves
this lemma
it allows us to say we can pretend that
we have noisy access
to this exponential sum in a band
limited
sense so now we're faced with a nice
math question
which is we have an exponential sum that
we're only allowed to query at some
particular band limited locations
and we have a different kind of inverse
problem you know can we
can we solve the inverse problem for
this exponential sum and figure out
what lambdas of j's are in it and what
mu sub js are in it
that's the real problem that we want to
solve to solve our optics problem that
we started off with so let me tell you a
really
basic strategy first there's something
trivial you can try and do
this is already going to give us some
good algorithms in the case where we
have a constant number of sources
so you know i have this band limited
access to this function
f of omega this exponential sum one
thing you can do is you know
2d problems 2d exponential sum problems
are actually not that easy to reason
about sometimes
so one thing you can do is you can
choose a line
in fourier space and maybe you only
query f of omega along that line
so that's even further restricting the
places that you're accessing f of omega
and maybe just that information about
what f omega looks like
along this line intersected with this
disk
is enough to reconstruct the parameters
of the exponential sum
now it's good to keep in mind that we're
working in fourier space here so what
does this
strategy look like when you're talking
about the original image that you're
observing that's a mixture of airy disks
well you know intersecting with a line
in fourier space is actually the same
thing as projecting onto the line in the
original space
so what this means is that you're taking
this mixture of airy disk this is
actually an image taken from a cell
and what you're doing by restricting to
the line is you're going to project
all of the arie disks onto that line now
there's a big problem with that which is
that if you originally had separation
delta
all of the centers of these different
hairy disks were by assumption
delta separated from each other by
projecting onto the line you might
accidentally make the separation
much smaller now it turns out that
that's not
going to be a big deal when you talk
about only having a constant number of
sources
so actually that strategy is going to do
pretty well and it's going to work to
give us the first
theorem that i told you that there is no
diffraction limit when you talk about
any constant number of sources
so let's try and make this rigorous so
what does it mean and what does it look
like mathematically
when i only query f of omega along this
line
now i claim in fact let's only query it
along a line at some discrete
set of points so along this line i'm
going to query it at the point a
and then i'm going to query f of omega
at the point a plus b
and then i'll query it at a plus 2b and
then a plus 3b
and so on so what i claim is that this
actually
the measurements that we observe from
measuring f of omega at these points
it looks like a matrix vector product
where your matrix
is a van der man matrix and your vector
you know has to do with the um the
mixing weights
in your mixture model so to be precise
when i
think about this exponential sum
remember that this f omega function
well what it did was it put you know it
had e to the minus
2 pie i and then it took the inner
product of mu j
and omega and when i plug in for omega
something like
a or a plus b or a plus 2 b
or a plus 3 b then there's some part
that as i vary the constant in front of
the b
i'm raising to a higher and higher power
that's where i'm pulling out this alpha
sub j term
is it's the inner product in b and mu j
and i'm raising that to a higher and
higher power
as i look at successive measurements
along the points along this line
and then i pull out the mixing weights
the lambdas of js
along with the actual constant the a
that i started with
and that's exactly what i get is that
this is now when i multiply this van der
man matrix times this vector of
coefficients
i'm evaluating an exponential sum at
these locations
of omega so that's mathematically what
is going on
in this problem is that we're observing
this
van der bond matrix times this vector
and now we want to solve the inverse
problem of figuring out what these mu
sub js are and what these
lambda sub js are
okay so you know this is really the um
the last talk
and the tutorials i don't want to get
too technical so i'm just going to
assert
that there is a beautiful algorithm out
there called the matrix pencil method in
fact
you know just like generic's algorithm
it's actually something that
has been rediscovered tons and tons of
times across different communities
it's kind of funny how often it's been
rediscovered
and it's also like generics algorithms
based on solving
some generalized eigenvalue problems now
the catch is that it's something that's
really designed to work without noise
so the basic theorem for the matrix
pencil method
is that when you have a sum of
exponentials
and it's k exponentials it turns out
that you can evaluate those
k that sum of k exponentials at any two
k plus one
noise uh you know locations provided you
do it noiselessly
and there is an efficient algorithm to
perfectly recover
the parameters of the exponentials you
get the mixing weights and what actually
shows up in the exponent
so that's really neat but you know in
our setup
noise is unavoidable because we only
have access to a finite number of
photons
we only get to record their location
with some finite precision
and that's the main question is really
to understand
you know how the sample complexity
depends on k so we
we don't want to work in this noiseless
setup we want to tackle
head-on what happens when we have noise
now you can ask the question does the
matrix pencil method work with noisy
measurements
it turns out that the answer is you know
it works if and only if this generalized
eigenvalue problem
is itself somewhat stable and a few
years ago i had analyzed it for
reasons that i won't get into this talk
but i showed that you can actually
analyze the stability of the matrix
pencil method
and it's stable if and only if the
condition number of that van der man
matrix
is bounded so that's the key point is
that when i described
how the measurements were observing look
like a vanderbond matrix
times a vector then there is an
algorithm to actually
invert and solve what that mixture of
exponentials looks like
that works if and only if the van der
bond matrix isn't too close
to being singular
so what we can show in our paper is that
you know let's say you started off
with delta separated centers to begin
with in two dimensions
in this observation plane and then you
choose a random line and project onto
that line
well then what's going to happen is that
your minimum separation with high
probability will only decrease
in the sense that it'll go from delta to
delta over k
squared and what you can do is you can
show
that the van der bond matrix has a lower
bound on its smaller singular value
that it's not worse than exponentially
small and
let's say k squared there is of course
some dependence on the minimum
separation
because as you move some mu j very close
to some mu
i then that means that two of the
columns in the van der man matrix are
getting closer and closer to each other
and you are getting closer to being
singular so the intuition for this is
really just that the van der man matrix
you know it's oftentimes ill-conditioned
but when you only have k columns it's
not arbitrarily ill-conditioned it's at
worst exponential and k
ill conditioned in fact for those who
don't think too much about these kinds
of things
you know solving systems of linear
equations in van der waals matrices
that really has a lot to do with like
things like polynomial interpolation
so figuring out the coefficients of a
polynomial a degree k polynomial
only from being able to query it at some
locations
these kinds of things you can do and
there's you know you at worst
exponentially blow up the noise
so what this lemma means for us is that
all we have to do is we can try that
strategy we take our mixture of area
discs we try a line
and we project onto that line and we get
an exponential and k
running time and sample complexity
algorithm to learn
the locations of the projections of the
centers
and it turns out the way that you can
piece together where the centers are in
2d is you can just
try another line and stitch together
which centers correspond to which
projections
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to take a step back and try and address
really the most
interesting question which is you know
what happens on higher you know in
what happens when you don't on
exponential and k dependence
so the first thing that i want to
mention is that actually it turns out
that in 1d the smallest singular value
of a vandermonde matrix
it turns out that there are conditions
under which the
smallest singular value is not
exponential and k small
it turns out that provided you have a
separation condition
compared to some kind of cutoff
frequency about you know how many rows
you have in this van der bond matrix
provided that the cutoff frequency is at
least let's say one over the min
separation
then you can prove a lower bound of the
smallest singular value that's not
exponentially small
so this is kind of neat i'm not going to
tell you how exactly this was proven but
it turns out that a key thing that's
used in the proof of this is something
called an extremal function that if you
take something
called if you take the sine function sgn
so it's you know zero when x is negative
and then it jumps up to plus one that's
a very
not smooth function and what you can do
is you can ask well
is there a good smooth approximation in
fact what you can do is you can ask well
i want a function
which measurizes it so it's everywhere
at least as large as the sine function
that function this red function should
have the property that its fourier
transform
is supported for in the range minus one
to one
and among all such functions i want to
minimize the l1 distance between the red
function
to the black function now it turns out
that the exact
optimal answer is known it's called the
burling selberg majorent
and correspondingly there's a minerant
and you can use these extremal functions
as a way to precondition the van der
maan matrix to show that it's not
exponentially ill-conditioned provided
that the separation
is lo you know as large compared to the
cut-off frequency
so um you know we could hope for the
same type of phase transition in two
dimensions
maybe if the centers are separated from
each other in two dimensions
even though we only have band limited
access to the function
maybe it's possible that we can get a
poly and k running time and sample
complexity algorithm
but there's going to be a big problem
with this strategy is that i claim
there are situations where you have
point sources in 2d
but no 1d projection is going to work
because it's going to destroy the
separation too much
so let's think about this
two-dimensional problem
i claim that there are 2d configurations
where there is no 1d projection that
even
approximately preserves the minimum
separation without it reducing by
something like a poly and k
factor in fact there's a really simple
construction for that
i'm going to create pairs of point
sources they're going to be delta
separated from each other
and then i'm going to create another
pair that's far away but i'm going to
rotate it slightly
and then i take another pair and i
rotate it slightly and so on
until i cover all of the different
angles
and now what happens is any 1d
projection you choose
well there will be a pair that almost
collides on top of each other when you
project
onto that line and in fact this isn't
just
a failure of this technique of trying to
reduce from the 2d problem to 1d
it's actually because the true threshold
for the 1d problem is actually bounded
above
1. so we actually proved that 1.15
threshold
that the true diffraction limit is
actually strictly larger than it is for
the 1d
problem so instead we use
a miracle which is that it turns out
through
um just sheer black magic to me
that there's been some very recent
progress on understanding
two dimensions and higher dimensional
extremal functions
they nailed exactly what are the optimal
higher dimensional extremal functions
in the analogous way to the burling
selberg major in 1d
so there's a beautiful result of
gonclavez actually very recent from 2018
which shows that for some target radius
r that again
has to do with something to do with
bessel functions well there is a
function
m that satisfies the following three
amazing conditions
so first of all it's going to minorize
the indicator function of the unit ball
that's similar to how we looked at
majorants and minorans for the burling
selberg majorant
now we also want m to be a smooth
approximation
so we want that when we take the fourier
transform of m
that it has bounded support in fact we
want that its support
is contained within a ball of radius r
so you get to choose an r between these
two constants
which characterizes the smoothness of
your function at least in terms of its
fourier transform
and you want it to minorize the ball but
now you want it to in some sense
be a non-trivial approximation so you
want
m hat of 0 to be strictly positive
so this is kind of a mouthful but let's
just try and digest this by saying some
trivial things
what if i ignored the third condition so
i want a function
m of x that minorizes the indicator of
the ball
it should have bounded fourier transform
well if i ignore the third condition
then there's kind of an easy way to do
that
m of x is equal to zero that works right
so the third condition says that i want
to do strictly better than the all zero
function
and what they know is they know that
tight bounds on the radius where that
isn't is not possible these are the
optimal answers in 2d and in fact
there's an expression in higher d for
the optimal answer in higher d
where there is a non-trivial smooth
minorizer for the indicator of the unit
ball
in fact these things really are black
magic to me so these
bounds arise through the study of de
brunso spaces of entire functions
if you understand that sentence
congratulations you're probably a phd in
harmonic analysis
to me these are just words it's still a
kind of mysterious thing what exactly
this notion of de brunja spaces
is and how exactly it leads itself to
being able to
anal you know analytically compute these
optimal extremal functions
it really does look like a miracle to me
but it turns out that there's another
strategy for learning
exponential sums that doesn't require
reducing to 1d
so there's an approach of huang and
kakade whose approach is actually
literally based on generic's algorithm
and instead what they need in order to
apply generic's algorithm and analyze
its noise stability
is instead they create a matrix that
looks you know it's not the van der maan
matrix we saw before
it still has these exponential terms in
here but now instead of plugging in
you know omega and 2 omega and 3 omega
you're plugging in arbitrary values
omega sub 1 omega sub 2 all the way up
to omega sub m
and what you care about is the condition
number of this matrix and it turns out
that you can use these 2d extremal
functions
to give a tight bound on when random
omega js
actually have bounded condition number
which is really
and what this tells us is that all of
these things together
coupled with our lower bound of this
1.15 that's an explicit construction of
things you can't resolve
as it shows us that um you know a bunch
of the purported diffraction limits
which were
you know asserted as being the right
constants well we can't pin it down
exactly
because it's still a rather challenging
problem in harmonic analysis
but we can pin it down to a range that
you know
the only things which survive this kind
of scrutiny are raleigh's condition
and something called the buxton
condition which is actually a fairly
obscure one
and um you know let me just poke fun at
carol sparrow so this is with all due
apologies to
carol sparrow's friends and colleagues
who clearly saw the undulation criteria
was the right one
it turns out to fall outside of the
interval to which we can pin down the
diffraction limit
so finding the sharp diffraction limit i
think is a super interesting
very challenging question because i
think it literally is equivalent to some
type of problem in harmonic analysis
about
you know optimal bounds for solving
these inverse problems of
exponential sums under querying it only
in bounded frequency locations
so let me just in the last two minutes
you know take a step back because this
was something that i alluded to but
you know in theoretical machine learning
we have lots of provable algorithms for
some types of parameter learning
problems
one that i've certainly spent a lot of
my time thinking about are things like
learning mixtures of gaussians and
there's a nice story about how these
arose way back in the 1890s
in carl pearson's work where he was
studying some sort of you know
biological
statistics of naples crabs and he
believed that it was
explained as a mixture of two gaussians
now in a lot of those settings in
biology or when we apply it in machine
learning
we don't literally believe that the
problem is actually a mixture of two
gaussians
because you know a mixture of two
gaussians has infinite support
and i don't think that there are crabs
whose forehead size is negative
so these are at best approximations to
the data that you're observing they
might be pretty good fits in some
contexts and we have provable algorithms
for learning these kinds of parametric
models
but you know i do spend my time sitting
in a math department and when i talk to
applied mathematicians
they solve a lot of inverse problems
with
differential equations and if you think
about learning a mixture of gaussians
it's like solving an inverse problem
with the heat equation
because you start off with some sort of
nicer distribution maybe if the two
gaussians are the same variance
you start off with two delta functions
and you can evolve by a gaussian
and that corresponds to taking that heat
profile and running it forwards
and then you're really asking the
question if i observe this heat profile
what did it look like at some earlier
time
so a bunch of our learning algorithms
really are proofable algorithms for some
types of
inverse problems on differential
equations
and the same thing is happening here in
optics but what's kind of exciting is
that
you know for an airy disk it's not
really an approximation of the problem
when you have a star
and you're observing it through a lens
it is
actually an airy disc that you observe
and in fact your lens is basically
spherical because they use all kinds of
techniques to make the lens
very very spherical you know the amount
of deviation and its boundary between
being a perfect sphere
is just absolutely infinitesimal
compared to the radius of the thing
so in optics resolution has an inverse
problem for a different
kind of differential equation where the
airy disk is the thing that's the
corresponding greens function
and yet many of these ideas about how to
proofably deconvolve using the fourier
transform
actually can be adapted so let me end on
this hopeful note which is that
you know maybe there's more to do with
these kinds of things that maybe we're
selling ourselves short
so when we have provable algorithms and
theoretical machine learning
maybe there are ways to actually solve
inverse problems in the sciences
particularly ones that come
through differential equations and maybe
these kinds of insights about what we
can probably do
what heuristics we can rigorously
analyze and what we can prove is just
fundamentally off limits in terms of
sample complexity
are things that can really say something
meaningful to these other communities
that seem to me
to be trying to solve related things
so let me stop there and let me
summarize what i hope you got out of it
so the diffraction limit even though you
may not have thought about inverse
problems in optics before i certainly
hadn't
until i read this nobel prize citation
for the super resolution cameras
well these are literally mixture model
problems and they're learning problems
that's what those
inverse problems mean and even though
there were so many heuristic arguments
for the existence of a diffraction limit
i think there's a huge value trying to
to try to put these on some rigorous
foundations
to try and understand fundamental limits
and optics
particularly as a statistical phase
transition because i think
statistical considerations aren't always
things that arise
in these debates and you know i'd love
to see other people
try and solve inverse problems in the
sciences which maybe
might be amenable to other tools from
theoretical machine learning some of the
types of things that i've
discussed in in this tutorial so
thanks very much and happy to take any
questions you guys might have
thanks ankur um so
at this point uh if you have a question
that you'd like to ask out loud please
raise your hand and
nike will unmute you but let's first try
to handle
questions from the q a
do you think the gap in the phase
transition constants you derive
is a statistical and computational gap
or do you believe one of the sides isn't
tight
so i don't believe that there's a
computational for statistical gap for
this problem that's a great question
but maybe your question gives me an
opportunity to say something that you
know i was
i was supposed to say but i forgot so
you see when you have
two airy disks there were tons of
heuristics in astronomy for trying to
deconvolve binary disk
and those heuristics were brute force
search you brute force search for the
two centers
and you check how well your fit is and
if it's a sufficiently good fit you say
aha that must have been the answer if
it's not you say maybe it's just one
disc after all
but it turns out that you know when you
want to try and solve the problem for a
larger number of centers
k that then you know it's not just the
sample complexity but your algorithm
would also be
running in exponential and k time so
even if you were above the diffraction
limit and you had some kind of
separation among the centers
enough so that you in principle could
get by with poly and k sample complexity
their heuristics still ran in
exponential and k time
so when you talk about k being large
there is still the possibility as you're
you know pointing out
that there could be you know it might be
possible that you can do something in
poly and k
sample complexity but maybe not
algorithmically i guess i'm just an
optimist that you know i think many of
the tools
for reasoning about why the problem is
statistically well posed
they really have to do with creating
test functions that precondition
certain types of you know matrices that
have exponentials
in them and i think a lot of those
preconditioners lend themselves to more
clever types of greedy search
so this is really just a belief on my
part that
so far i haven't seen any techniques for
reasoning about the statistical
well-posedness
that don't seem like they wouldn't also
inform natural search heuristics within
algorithms that avoid the exponential in
k
thanks and anna asks is there a
connection to the heisenberg uncertainty
principle
uh absolutely absolutely absolutely so
uh let me actually just make sure that
i've framed what the um
you know the burling selberg majorent is
properly but see the thing is that there
are many different formulations of what
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
means
um you know and there are much simpler
things that you know
phrase the heisenberg uncertainty
principle in different ways that look
more familiar for a physicist
so um but let me maybe not get into
those but
one way to phrase the um you know the
burling selberg matron is just that
you know if you uh have bounded for a
transform you're bounded within the your
support is from minus one to one
then your l1 distance to the sine
function can
has to be at least one and it's
achievable by the burling selberg
majorant so you can think about this as
some kind of
you know if you're a good approximation
to the sine function then you must be
spread out
kind of thing but it's a little bit more
subtle to connect it really to the
physics versions
that you see in the heisenberg
uncertainty principle
[Music]
we can talk more about that offline
because i think maybe that wasn't the
best answer but
so i had a question as well so um
i guess that these problems are uh
two-dimensional problems because your
observation plan is two-dimensional
but i guess maybe there's a way to push
the diffraction limit
down if you have a third dimension as
well
so my sense is that the diffraction
limit in 3d
depending on how you phrase it would be
larger
so i know that for these extremal
functions that you get
from you know these de brunja spaces if
you compute what's this critical radius
where you have a non-trivial
approximation that threshold actually
does get worse
and it kind of comes from the fact that
like you could embed this 2d
thing into 3d arbitrarily that's the
same way that you know the way that we
had this tight
visualization of what these total
variation curves looked like
came from assuming that all the point
sources were on 1d which is a setting
where we can actually perfectly resolve
what the threshold is this is one
but the other thing that i should
mention is that see i mean
what's kind of funny is um so this gun
clothes paper
uh you know it's in the proceedings of
the ams i think from 2018
and it has um one citation
which is our paper so you know they
studied this for very very different
reasons
and one of the funny things is that you
know you can study all different
versions
of these extremal problems in harmonic
analysis
and instead of asking for like
majorizing or minorizing the
l2 ball you can ask it for like the l
infinity ball or things like this
and here there are super wide gaps
between what is and
isn't possible that have dimension
dependence factors
so what's kind of interesting is that
they study it for kind of different
reasons within harmonic analysis
actually the original reason for the
burling selberg majorent was to use it
in analytic number theory
because what you do is you don't create
a smooth approximation of the sgn the
sine function
you create a smooth approximation to an
indicator function of an interval
and you use that through an exponential
sum to count how often primes
modulo some constant land in the
interval
and because it's a smooth test function
that becomes easier to use
analytic tools and the fact that it's
sandwiching gives you a bound on the
error guarantees
so it's really funny and this is more
maybe a wild pontification
but you know see when i think about all
right the matrix pencil method
uh works when you have no noise
that's great but it doesn't really tell
you what are the real limits because you
only see the emergence of the
diffraction limit when you add noise
and actually you can see the same
parallel in the way that number three
developed a lot of the first tools were
purely asymptotic
you know for how often like if you take
like an irrational number and you look
at integer multiples of it whether that
modulo one becomes uniform along the
interval from zero to one
and then people started asking questions
like quantitatively how cr
how close is it and how fast does it
converge to the
you know to the to the standard density
and those types of tools end up being
very useful like quantitative bounds to
actually get
stability balance for us for like how
many samples do we need if we don't have
an infinite number of samples
so i think a lot of these things are
interesting but it's kind of amazing
to me that like we need some versions of
these
extremal function problems and they're
studied in different communities not
because what we care
but you know because what's interesting
to them for other reasons
so i find myself not knowing you know in
the extremal questions that i want to
solve for learning problems
even having an idea of what it is that's
in their wheelhouse that they might or
might not be able to solve
and i don't understand debrange's spaces
but if someone would like to explain it
to me i would
love for that to happen
is there a computer science equivalent
to the second law of
thermodynamics where effectively you
just can't know the past
from the knowledge of the present and
you can't solve the inverse problem
okay so you know there's a lot going on
in that question
so i'll say the following so when people
study it in applied math
like inverse problems with differential
equations
they study it in a very different way
actually in step one than the way that
we do it in theoretical computer science
you know when we learn mixtures of
gaussians we're solving an inverse
problem with the heat equation that's
what it
is they solve inverse problems with the
heat equation too
and they use fourier transforms they
divide by the kernel
but the difference is the assumptions
that you start off with so for the most
part what they assume about the initial
data
is the exact opposite so they assume
that the initial data is smooth
maybe the right soba love space you know
that kind of thing
and we assume that it's not smooth at
all it's some sort of set of delta
functions but the key is that it's a
parametric assumption
because there are few centers and really
the theoretical computer science version
of like which heat equations you cannot
invert
are the things which have too many
parameters it's a mixture of too many
gaussians you cannot learn it
it's a mixture of too many arie discs
you cannot learn it
and that's different than the versions
in applied math that i see for the most
part which are
this function is not smooth enough so i
cannot reliably invert the heat equation
so to me that's one of the interesting
things about how we pose inverse
problems
is that they're set up in different ways
we start off with different kinds of
assumptions
and i'm not sure there's a one-to-one
marriage between the techniques but i'd
love to understand a dictionary of what
things work and which things don't
there are also some really neat
connections between um
things that go way back when to like
samuel carlin called like
total positivity that have a lot to do
with what we do with like those are
other systems of functions
that have the same types of unique
interpolation properties
as do uh you know bounded degree
polynomials
and that's something that i see much
more in applied math happening but you
know i haven't seen this thought about
within theoretical computer science
so i have a minor technical question if
it's okay
um which is that when you did the
before taking the fourier transform you
did a kernel density estimate for your
you receive points but why do you need
it because uh
before you transfer that's a great
question so i didn't quite go into that
because it would have been too many
norms but
um so if you have a smooth function row
of x right
and it doesn't even matter what row of x
is and you're in finite dimensions
because these things go out the window
when you look at high dimensions
so now you take a bunch of samples from
it that depends on your smoothness
parameter
and then you convolve by kernel density
you know by a gaussian whose variance
depends on the number of samples and
your smoothness
and what you'll get is you'll get a good
l infinity approximation
and that when you take the fourier
transform we'll transform into an l1
exactly so really you know you just have
to keep track of what's the right norm
for your approximation it's not actually
important other than just working out
all of the details how they
should work to be precise because all of
these things converge to zero and it
doesn't really matter it's good to do it
with the right rates but
none of these things because of finite
dimensions actually matter very much
i actually had a few questions but it's
kind of late so maybe let me
just ask one yeah do you have a good
example
of a deconvolution problem
in actually in high dimensions like in
practice that people need to solve
uh oh in practice
um practice is tough or or maybe not
high dimensions but you know not two
more like
you know
you know so i'm not sure all of them
really so i mean
i'll say that this optics problem i
think is one of the simplest problems to
try and make the connections between an
inverse problem to the things that are
studied within theoretical computer
science
because it is a mixture model and it's
the same type of thing we study
um my sense is that a lot of the other
inverse problems that we study and
the people studying the sciences they
they don't look like
convolution or mixture models types of
problems
you know a lot of them are you know come
from optics or
like sort of having noisy 2d projections
of 3d things like that happens a lot in
cryo-em
so it just kind of looks a little bit
different to me but let me still try and
give one
interesting technical question now i'm
not sure it's going to fit the bill of
being a practical thing per se
but one of the things that people do
care about is you know back in my first
lecture i talked about
you know algorithms for learning
mixtures of gaussians
now one of the things that people study
is can you learn mix of gaussians just
on a separation condition
on the centers and there there's been a
lot of progress that
you know for the longest time the best
known bounds were actually
k to the one quarter if you have k
different um
you know gaussians in and they're
spherical in n dimensions
and that threshold came from just some
concentration of measure types of things
because when you have you know two
gaussians in like n dimensions
when they're like end of the one quarter
separated that's when a sample from one
will be closer to its center
than it will be to the other center and
it just has to do with the overlap
so the k to the one quarter came from
the fact that you find the space where
all the centers live in the
k-dimensional space
and you use that same separation
condition now through sum of squares
people have gotten the separation
condition
down to k to the epsilon but in
principle you could actually get it down
to root log k
and that's the optimal bound information
theoretically
and one of the things that i wonder is
you know when they're all actual
spherical gaussians it is a
deconvolution problem and this is
usually used as a proxy for like how
well can you solve a clustering problem
from some generative model and for that
type of thing what you really need
is you need some types of you know
functions
that you can divide by that sort of have
some very steep decay but have bounded
fourier transform
and what's kind of amazing is that
there's an entire theory for studying if
i have bounded transform
fourier transform what decay rate can i
get in the limit because that's burling
moly of n theory
but what's not known are effective
bounds on how quickly they decay
for finite bounds instead of in the
limit so i don't actually know the
answers to
that but specifically for these extremal
function problems that come through de
brunja spaces
these things are known really through a
miracle like i don't understand it and i
haven't yet figured it out
so i would say that there are learning
problems from simple generative models
where you know creating good test
functions might actually have something
to say about you know can you cluster
under much weaker separation conditions
potentially cool thanks
but unfortunately i've never taken an
analysis course in my life so i don't
know any analysis i think there is
actually there are some related
questions in
convicts geometry that okay
um i mean some of the same spirit
kind of you have a convex body that you
know
you have some distribution that's
supported inside it
and you want to prove bounds on you know
the fourier transform can't be supported
in the dual
of the complex body stuff like that
and are some of the tools okay of the
same spirit
so the burling molly then theory as far
as i can tell i mean it's through these
multipliers like fourier multipliers
techniques and it seems very ineffective
sort of fundamentally for the tools but
it's kind of tricky because there's so
many proofs of these facts
but maybe for some of the like high
dimensional convex geometry
some of those things i imagine might be
more effective or quantitative
and the things that are known or neat
i'll have to
i'll have to ping you for some
references
with this be an approach to get quasi
subquasi polynomial time algorithms for
spherical
mixtures at separation squared log d yes
that's why i asked it
thanks
any more questions
okay so uh if not thanks again ankur for
this
excellent lecture series thank you to
all of the speakers in the boot camp
it's been a really exciting eight days
and uh with this we we conclude the the
boot camp series for the high
dimensional
program so thank you very much we'll
have one less coffee break in the gather
town